hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester it's the
England versus level Ireland the to
classical games between the two of them
have ended in a draw and now we are
going into the first game of the rapids
and well it's a really interesting game
today they're gonna play two rapid games
and four blitz games and if needed they
will also go into tiebreaks and even up
to Armageddon so we'll see how it goes
and how many videos we'll will check out
today but already in round one a very
interesting game so I do hope you enjoy
it without further ado let's check it
out dink with the white pieces opens
with d4 sorry about that
so d4 by dink
we have nice to have six by eleven c4 e6
and the knight to f3
we have d5 so the Queens gambit the
client is on the board
nice to see three and Bishop to e7 with
Bishop to f4 and the castle so following
the game dingo already played against
how there is a fellowship in the World
Cup that the magic that ding of course
one since he won the World Cup with III
and Knight B to d7 Bishop d2 preparing
the castle and now D captures and c4
with castles biding and here in the game
ding vs. ferocious rotor played c5 ding
wounded game very nicely but here with a
six by 11 we have a for preventing b5 as
you also do want to recapture on c4 now
and Knight to d5 now and here there is
one game from 2015 world rabbit
championship Vasilyevich Chuck vs. David
Navarro where Bishop to g3 was played
but and that deadly man didn't grow up
here dingos for Bishop captures on c4
even though Nevarez move is the the
engine stop recommendation ding
obviously prepared something nice with
the Bishop to c4 line as it is a new
move so already as a move 10 we have a
completely new game ok Knight captures
on f4 we have a captures an f4 now
allowing the doubling of the F pawn but
you have very nice control of the e5
square something that's seen in a lot of
openings the the London system comes to
mind
now with c5 by 11 and now
d captures on c5 the ship captures on c5
and Queen to e2 putting a lot of well
perhaps unwanted pressure on the undie
e6 pawn with b6 now preparing to
vignette to the light square bishop and
rook a to d1 hoping to harass the black
Queen with Queen to e7
and now dink pushes the Queen back just
look after a one and now Knight to f6
might might be the way to go but here 11
played the g6 he doesn't like all the
pressure they are piling up on the King
side but this allows the thing to start
really harassing the black Queen we have
nice to d5 and here of course you cannot
capture a pass since the Queen on e7 is
hanging well you could capture it each
character son b5 but then white will get
a slight edge for example it captures
Queen captures on e7 you do have to
recapture the Queen and then first
before recapturing you get Bishop
captures on d5 a nice assertion - and
then only after the rook moves you will
recapture on e7 so here 11 decides it's
best to just move back to where we came
from Queen to d8 and the now comes
Knight to g5 really a beautiful piece
sacrifice by being as it just offers him
a whole other gameplay as you'll see he
captures on d5 by 11 Bishop captures on
d5 attacking the rook and not just rook
to e7 as it will be helpful defending
the seventh rank but now feel free to
post video and figure out what was doing
his idea in this position and why he
sacrificed the piece while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
finding such a nice move it's my
favorite move in the whole game of chess
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
that move is of course b4 before with
the idea that you don't really have a
good retreat square for the bishop if
here Queen just captures that if d6
well dangerous characters and f7 fall by
rook captures here it's not a problem
so here 11 played Bishop capture son
before but now you get Bishop captures
on f7 with check rook captures on f7 and
now Knight captures on f7 this comes
with an attack on the Queen and you
don't really have an option here if you
capture is just going to c4 check
moves and then you pick up the bishop on
before and yes you do have two pieces
for a rook but the knight cannot move
the bishop cannot move
whatever you do rook to e7 check is
coming there's no preventing that so all
of black's pieces are completely discord
innate 'add so after Knight characters
on f7 with Queen to f8 xi gets the Queen
out of harm's way
but now Knight back to d6 with Bishop
captures on d6 and now of course the
defending with a tactic Queen e6 check
King g7 and rook captures on d6 and here
rook the c7 by 11 also it's very hard to
unwind here for example if 95 with a
double attack just Queen e5 check and
the white is out of any problems King g8
you're gonna go a5 create some problems
for black here
you cannot capture as the night falls so
now if the knight moves and you don't
have a good square for the knight if
Knight b7 again the rook is not coming
into the game just rook f6 you attack
the Queen Queen d8 and now it captures
and b6 you push the rook back and now
you just want to play rook c7 followed
by something like this basically white
completely winning here so 11 played the
rook to c7 and now just g3 biding
defending DF for porn also getting rid
of any background weaknesses since the
king is now the king has the G 2 square
available for him and here you have to
play B 5 B 5 create a passed pawn and
try to try to use that to continue your
game but here 11 played a queen to f7
and Queen to f7 although you should
definitely trade Queens here you're the
one getting attacked it doesn't work it
completely blunders the game so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find out why it blunders the game while
I give you a couple of seconds again for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and finding such a nice
nice move with the rook as you will see
that the bishop is hanging and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's rook the c6 it's not an easy move
to find but once you see it and once you
know there's a move to find perhaps it's
it's you know do
point is if now the Queen's are traded
just rook captures on e6 and black
doesn't have a mood your look is under
attack if you move it you lose the
bishop if you don't move it if you if
you trade rooks then again your Bishop
is under attack you cannot defend it and
if there should be seven then just work
here and now you will start the winning
material and of course the game so after
Luke c6 11 played rook captures on c6
but it's not much better just Queen
captures on c6 again there's no good way
to save the bishop Queen to f8 yes you
are defending it but now rook the c1 add
another attacker to the bishop
we have Knight the c1 tonight to c5 now
blocking the rooks attack also the roof
is now no longer covering the c8 square
but just Queen captures on b6 now create
a double attack on the night here the
knight again has to move and now you
just repeat Queen to c6 and the bishop
still doesn't have anywhere to go
it's just a very very hard position to
play we have night the d4 now here 11
without with a few poisonous tricks in
the end hoping for
well Queen characters and mighty to
check where after King of 1 you will
maybe be able to save this endgame it is
a rapid game after all both players are
somewhat low on time living much lower
but it's still 5 points against 3
chances are ending would win this again
without all that many problems so after
94 I think just plays the more precise
quintet c7 check first forces the King
away from the defense of the Queen we
have king to h6 or if you go something
like this then going to c4 check it's
very unpleasant we'll pick up the knight
or if you move the knight only then do
you pick up the bishop so here came to
h6 but now we in character sin see it
and now it's different since if this
night now checks you don't have time to
pick up the rook since your queen is
hanging here so Queen to e7 by 11 but
now rook to d1 attacking the knight
Knight to f3 check King G - and now
Quinta efore threatening all sorts of
nasty discoveries but being here very
you know called
cold-bloodedly plays King to h3 he just
gets out of the
the nasty discoveries and now 11 no
longer has any checks that that are
actually useful
so here 11 was extremely long time he
had like 15 seconds on the clock and
well his time almost ran out and then
his time ran out because he picked up
the night he played 94 and before he
pressed the clock his time ran out and
then he lost the game on time but it
doesn't really matter as now dink has a
forced mating to which I'm sure you all
can see without even pausing the video
yes that that is correct its Quinta f8
check King age 5 and now g4 will be
checkmate so a game one of the rapids
goes to ding and it's well a nice little
payback for 411 beating ding in the in
the World Cup not this one the previous
one in the finals so we'll see what
happens next game 11 gets the white
pieces and the well we again probably
will have a very interesting game but
we'll just have to wait and see so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
a nice rapid game from from the day to
day 3 I would like to thank Brock our
second Mario Encinos and Pollock slow-mo
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Grantchester finals
continue to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course starting in
the next big saga so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day